free Charlene is coverage
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and hello out there in podcast land it's
13 o'clock podcast episode 43 that's
right we had a good guest today yeah we
don't usually have guests but when we do
have a guest we tend to have an awesome
one yeah it's a GP he came back again
yeah way back on if you guys remember
way back on episode 4 we had the angry
gay Pope on talking about it was called
a turbulent Scientology that's right
yeah and we had such a good time with
him and he's such a cool guy and such a
funny guest and we've been wanting to
get him back so we finally got him to
come back and do an interview and we're
very very excited about yeah we promise
to have him back as a semi-regular so
we'll probably have him you know maybe
twice a year
yeah we're shooting for December again
yeah yeah he's good a touch bases with
see what Scientology's up to he's been
on a few missions and new missions and
he's got some new videos out on his
channel yeah so we did a show about what
he's been up to lately it's pretty cool
yeah so definitely go check out his
website which is anger gave hope calm
and check out his YouTube channel which
you can find just by searching angry gay
poper I think his channel is called the
end of Scientology yeah and if you don't
know who Agent P or aggregate Pope is go
back and watch the first show first and
then come back with this one yeah
absolute right yeah okay this one he
kind of like if you don't really know
that much about Scientology some of the
stuff he said might might not make it
might be over your head you want to go
back to the first gen he can give you
kind of a basic training that you need
to understand what it is but honestly if
you've been watching like Leah Remini
show you'll know then you'll know what
he's talking about and you know what I'm
gonna do some pictures and stuff like
that that he has from his website why
not yeah well what else is going on
books been selling real well hand over
fist oh thanks guys and yeah thank you
very much to everyone who has bought my
new book and my old ones too because
those seem to be selling they're gonna
cross sell on each other that's awesome
and podcast numbers have gone up we have
to have at least maybe 2,000 regular
listeners on the podcast which is
awesome yeah and if you guys are podcast
members only please come back and
subscribe to our channel on the youth
musician yes we know how many of you are
and also of like like and subscribe all
that kind of stuff you know the drill
know the drill you know and go to our
Facebook page and like us go to Twitter
and follow us and blah blah we also
still have samples on all the books oh
yeah audio I don't have many left of the
unseen hand but I have some of the other
ones and we may be able to ask and I
might remission yeah and I might get
permission to get more if you know if I
run out right so they might give me some
more codes if I ask them very nicely
yeah but you have to leave a review yes
you don't leave a review it won't give
me anything you suck and we yet not
really we love you guys and also shout
out to project Entertainment Network and
Armand Rosa Millia we actually saw him
this past weekend we were we recorded
some episodes of the scribblers rest
podcast where they it's like a gaming
podcast we were playing pathfinders
right so it's like you know you're doing
like a role-playing game and you just
kind of [ __ ] around and yeah they
record it and everything there's fun it
was really fun and I had never played
Pathfinder before but I say I think we
did okay kill the couple monsters I did
oh yeah I supported the team is there
anything else we got - we got some black
I don't think so I think that's probably
all the help we got to do right now
let's go ahead and start to show you
guys going to love this one this was
really funny
yeah so listen up the interview with the
angry gay Pope alright a GPS but been a
while man we have had you on the show
for I think for nine months huh yeah it
was episode war yeah yeah we've been
that we've been busy my friend I met
nasty Nathaniel and I have been doing
videos together and he's been involved
in cop block and doing things going to a
police and other locations and like
doing what science halls is called a
loud investigation to them and and
poking them and see what happens I go
it's much more fun to like poke
Scientology because then they'll get 10
times more cops here for you you just
check the cost you poke down so hold on
track up so you're actually protesting
the police that are associated with it
with Scientology is that what you said
yes you put them in an uncomfortable
situation like I just posted some videos
at my website anger gave up calm this
weekend of some police we met in San
Bernardino County California outside of
Scientology's quote secret vault where
some of their highest level operatives
may be like stored in a kind of
permanent concentration camp and he was
they were all so uncomfortable and that
was a misdemeanor trespassing charge
there were five cop cars not side there
were four cop cars five deputies one of
them was as a supervisor and they
detained us for like 20 minutes half an
hour whatever and we said you could find
these missing Scientologists in this
time if you had devoted this much
manpower than that which is a make a
night like human trafficking is a felony
okay just a little bit okay can you back
up and explain why don't you that were
20 feet from the spikes fence you know
it's like you don't have to be Nancy
Drew to investigators although you're
doing ok can you back up and explain to
the audience briefly what what it is
that you're talking about
this is a secret Scientology GRU lock
base right yes
so unlike most of Scientology which I
protest which is in Hollywood or maybe
even Riverside this is in San Bernardino
in an isolated outpost at rim of the
world it's called the town is called
Twin Peaks and it's just out of like
spooky David Lynch story but I fell
close I feel much more safe in the David
Lynch version at least during the
commercials you could get the hell out
of town so let me rage have you been on
in the past nine months I would say um
rage bean protests I would say one every
like three weeks yeah anything artwork
yes so the big deal started in January
when my protester nasty Nathaniel wanted
to go to the Inglewood ideal org so they
had and can't talk about and it's like
the Inglewood ideal work is a place the
church established in Inglewood about
five years ago and they owned a
beautiful building there and then
another beautiful building in the area
that's like an auditorium and he wanted
to go there and it's like been on my
checkoff box for a long time but I
haven't been there I could have gone to
the opening but I didn't because they
know that you're coming when there's an
opening so that the police are and
everybody's front loaded against you so
I don't show up for there's a lot yeah I
saw the way I saw the video of this one
it's awesome they even have this
particular it's almost like it's blatant
almost blaxploitation going on and that
you have it's like what do people what
did black people like fried chicken
let's go fried chicken at them while we
sing you know roller boogie from the
1970s oh yeah it even had a snake black
preacher up there but instead of in the
guys going berserk and instead of
talking about Jesus he's talking about
something something Scientology yeah up
the crowd and then um people with batons
and banners do cartwheels and the whole
events over they don't put that out
there so I had to I had to pull that off
of a video of some guy who was
affiliated with some of the musicians
and actors they hired for it and he took
it because otherwise they don't allow
that and it might even still be up but
yeah I grabbed it you got to grab that
stuff because they won't promote it or
show it and there's no other way to see
it and that that was the opening and we
showed up like five years later on
Martin Luther King Day so just by
coincidence it was Martin Luther King
Day and I'd like to st. Louis was such
clever marketing that we knew that the
church would all be out marching the
Martin Luther King parade with a book
like a bunch of wife of the crow's nest
unguarded I would love to say that was
our whole double plot but like it was
just dumb ass left I'd like there's a
Martin Luther King Day Parade and
they're all gone so there's like nobody
there in one of the locations we end up
wandering around there's only two people
in the building they're like I could
have infected their computers with
viruses are like rippled through their
logs of who's coming into this what's so
funny is that they're just
are in such bad shape if somebody shows
up and you can plainly see this in AGP
videos if someone goes to the org they
immediately call security
why are you doing it is that something
wrong it sounds wrong don't play with
your hair no one's usually in here why
are you here
it must be bad hilarious the only people
that end up showing up anymore are like
journalists smart asses you know
anonymous suits and people who have to
use the recipe when I was in Pasadena
seven or eight years ago the Pasadena
idea Lord there was no one in there but
us two protesters and this lady wanders
with this big cup of 7up and she wasn't
using bathroom right Dee and there was
the to remeber I've sort of gone in to
look I found out in Inglewood there was
there was at the one building I managed
to get into the bathroom and looking
there was but they may have been pegging
we'll get into the second building in a
second but the first building the ideal
word we walked into and yeah right away
like Security's furious they like I
shouldn't have said that I was here to
take pictures of architecture just like
that like taking pictures of the
architecture of a McDonald's the most
white bread most white bread
architecture ever but the other building
is an architectural Art Deco wonder and
use open as a jewelry store but the main
building the ideal org is like in this
one area of Englewood and they had a
security car outside I don't know why a
religion needs a security car maybe it
was like to make all the white people
who were forced to come there for
services feel secure even though there's
nobody in Englewood that can afford it
because it's like a middle class to
lower-class black neighborhood there's
nothing to see
and the building was empty forever but
they bought it in conjunction with
trying to get in with the Nation of
Islam which is another crazy cult but
they're like a black supremacist call
and the Scientologists have gotten
involved with them in Englewood because
they're a white supremacist call and
they're there they're making a sort of
Oreo cookie of supremacy
Oh God Oreo cookies hilarious cannot be
the title of the episode that will be
that will be the time of the ADP and the
Oreo cookie of supreme the mission of
Islam is behind everything they're
leaving that you don't know it insult
but it's all Scientology when you see it
up front and you go in and they've
replaced all their workers with these
video droids that like show videos that
you can see on the internet in your
bathrobe but you have to go there you
push a button and half of them are
either turned off or the volume is
turned off so it's like this is how
you're like propagating your like
precious religion it's like the you
replace everyone with robots and then
you turn the robot the volume off and
then they turn and then they turn the
followers into robots - yeah good point
and so I said to the security guard why
is that he goes oh um kids come in and
push the buttons and sonoran so like
most of them just be plugged in like Oh
give me a break and that should mean
like crazy like this is Fort Knox and
I'm going to take picture of something
god-awful and my friend Nancy Nathanael
tries to buy a book called Scientology
ethics and he just wants it as a
keepsake could say that he bought it
there and it was like $30 and you can
get it online for like nine bucks or
something it was $30 there and then he
gets to the cash register and the cash
register lady says oh there's a like $20
org tax and it's like fifty to fifty
right you know their taxes even though
the IRS said they can't be I would get
true or did that particular
Scientologist trying to take a cut yeah
maybe maybe she's just really boarded
yes like I'm standing here and just keep
it store all day but yeah I'm gonna get
a tip goddammit that's probably what
they promised me this so much and I'm
work here for a year and I made next to
nothing I'm gonna like gouge this guy
with a lie that's perfectly regular
Scientology thing you know let's like
this moment I don't give a [ __ ] about
later even though he tried to experience
Scientology he could not joke
that's it and like so then I sit down
and I get into their Scientology
Christmas catalogue which is still there
from December because it's only like
January 15th or whatever something like
that you know whatever Martin Luther
King Day Parade is and so I'm looking at
it it's like it's just like white-trash
Christmas where they have Scientology
jewelry with their symbols on and stuff
it's like as tacky is that's like the
Pope put out a catalog with you know
crucifix is covered with dripping
diamonds and [ __ ] like we all know how
like Jesus loved Gardens and bling
Tiffany goes right through the board to
the brook yes I say just take off take
will be pushed off Gannon unless others
are just for black people there so
there's all these extra black people in
them you would not see a dis left center
and Holly even their marketing is
targeted print wise down to the level of
what you sit down and see and the where
everybody stands has a big logo behind
it it's like in a video game when you
wander into a room and a space alien
something like there's a big symbol or
it sort of shows what the room is about
like in an opera or a video game and
they kind of hike on the first of the
bathrooms have the proper font and so we
went out of there before they could kick
us out and mind you we had turned our
cellphones off the entire day just to
make sure that they didn't find us and
even we visited my lawyer and I
definitely left my cell phone off there
I don't want them all knowing that like
we're in the same area because even
though they don't follow us that closely
maybe they are I don't know because but
we're going the offensive so like we're
going to drop into the defensive in
terms of communication that day does
that make sense yeah yeah so we get to
this second location and it was a
jewelry store that was built like in the
1920s or 30s and this gorgeous Art Deco
thing with a giant spire almost like a
church would have it's like the tallest
thing around we took pictures of the
spire far away I get to the back and the
whole back of the building is this huge
series of cage is like 50 feet across
you can see online of cell phone tower
equipment and the backup batteries if
the power fails and stuff like that this
huge thing from 18 t so 18 T is making a
ton of money off them you can see the
cell phone antennas up there on this
giant religious each aisle it was
originally a jewelry store I don't know
why they built it there maybe Englewood
was a
neighborhood but it's like the perfect
white elephant for them that like they
divide these buildings both of them an
angle where they were unoccupied for a
long time and then they totally tear
them apart and Rehab them and upgrade
them which is great even though they
totally cheat the law doing it but it's
just sad to see these like great
buildings that are kind of useless being
taken over by scumbags like this but
they are making a bunch of money off of
a TMT renting that place as a giant cell
phone tower that's it's only real
function I do think the people that were
built out of their money to buy this
Inglewood Community Center auditorium
will ever see any of that AT&T money now
of course not
yeah cam is like we got to get into
Inglewood the national Islam wants to
partner with us like why don't you want
more black people in Scientology are you
racist they got all this money together
to finally buy it and then it takes them
forever to upgrade it and then it takes
an even longer to do something else and
then once the Scientology has been
sucked out of money the great leader
takes the deed and just like monopoly
it's like is ifs if the Monopoly board
was covered with ants that gave you a
hotel and you just like God take it from
that minute it's gone so they're not
going to see any that money only a
church will and we go inside and like
first of all the door was locked but I
managed to make the woman behind it open
it with my voice towers I've used our
horse force powers to get into the
locked door at the hollywood educational
literacy project to the weak-minded
Elliot I can't do an Alec Guinness great
digit yeah so she opens it up I are you
closed
and she goes now come on in there's only
me here or whatever were like that we go
in and like she says sign in and drew
are welcome for him until I give them
[ __ ] information and it's a
shockingly beautiful building with this
unbelievably hot mural walking him go
like wow it's like you walked into like
the Jurassic Park building you know when
the movie starts it's like whoa and they
have a beautiful mural that has no
Scientology images in it or Bell ron
Hubbard or symbols or anything and it's
all about jazz and black people and it
could be any buildings mural so they
don't have to chip it out when they sell
it off later to bid profit
and she takes us past the typical video
bots and stuff like that I'm stoned out
of my mind on marijuana that my lawyer
had stuffed into my I got stoned at my
lawyers but where we went there sure
like they just a live marijuana like are
the six pairs I wear my marijuana crap
in multiple languages so she gets she
pushes in front of the video bot that we
saw at the other place again the like
volumes are off and stuff like that and
she leaves I have nastiness and you'll
sit there because I can't stand to look
at the [ __ ] video it's like it's like
throwing holy water on what years I
watch them I edited the mic I want to
sleep again it's together real life like
I just I don't want to hear about Ella
another who was born he was riding
Grange Broncos when he really five
Indians when he was only K and so
missing McDaniel was new to this like he
can he has a thicker skin that can
tolerate anymore and I walk back in the
back and it's like it is like Jurassic
Park this is lost world of like nobody
there exhibits and things and I went in
the bathroom when they had toilet paper
which is probably paid for by AT&T your
locals okay which is what reasons well
and then Decimus annals like he's going
to turn a cell phone honestly yeah put a
flash mob on your head and say look at
me we spent an entire day getting off
the cell phone good so they can't track
our whereabouts would not focus church
but the sleaze ball guys they hire and
if something big enough goes wrong they
kick the message up to the next person
who kicks it up to the next person
within an hour Miscavige narrows out of
them what does he got to do what they
already plays video games all day know
wouldn't surprise me actually I noticed
up for you videos that you have a new
cutie his name is Captain handsome
handsome man we'll get to him in a
minute but I just want to finish this
story so like that's a bit they have
toilet paper so that's good
so then nastiness annual I end up going
downstairs but first we turn on all the
computer
lay video bus to make lots of noise so
they won't hear what we're doing and it
sounds like we're consuming something
because she's just sitting at this desk
like half a mile away in this gigantic
building the temptu and we go downstairs
and like there's all the Scientology
places you seen the videos but it hasn't
it hasn't been used in five years
there's like the rooms where they sit
next to each other and stare at each
other and every room has a big symbol
one of the rooms had actually a symbol
of black people on against I mean it's a
sculpture each room has a major
expensive sculpture that goes into the
back of it like there's one room that
says the way to happiness room which I
don't know why it needs a room so it's a
brief brochure or like what you do is
stick people in there and make them read
it or something and there's a nursery
oh god that creeps me out yeah well if
they never use any of this stuff that's
sheriff yeah
they do mostly its Scientologists who've
been brought from rich white places to
come here and they're forced to do stuff
but the Nation of Islam has also had big
events here and Mayor Eric Garcetti and
the chief of police what's his name they
showed up and it's just sick but they I
go I go to some of my scientology
protest buddies who i said to one of
them who was on Leah Remini show I said
well how can they do that it's just
gross it's just awful both those
organizations are awful in it
Scientology right in front of building
because they have various constituencies
this was a event where gangs were
brought together like the Crips in the
blood to like bury the hatchet
so the Church of Scientology gets credit
for hosting it and I mean they get
credit for doing those things but the
day of the Nation of Islam or just like
Looney Tunes nut cases that have to be
stopped at any time you can yeah and so
we left that one and and the whole music
was Jurassic Park and it you can I used
to get in trouble making videos where I
just steal the music from Jurassic Park
even though they don't care because it's
an ad for Jurassic Park yeah even the
James Bond movie songs are all songs
with it the name and the thing so like
Live and Let Die makes you want to see
the movie so give the [ __ ] song away
right you can get into you can get it a
copyright problem so now I just go and I
do like Jurassic Park cover and all
these people have done these beautiful
versions of a certain song and I can use
it all through the video in different
ways so that you get like that you end
with a heavy-metal Jurassic Park and any
and like an another he's doing Jurassic
Park on the zither and it's very like
childlike and touch one do you there oh
my gosh golly Fame and then there's the
giddy up and go theme which is done that
I'm done
that's no use to me is this lost world
and I said it at the time I shoot her to
edit so I go there's bookstore full of
like l ron hubbard teachers children of
a spell is like a lot world i mean
there's like no no dust on it but like
only because somebody comes in and dust
once a while okay so now you want to
talk about captain Hanson yeah I want to
tell us about a look if explain cause
let me explain something to the audience
your work has made celebrities out of
many of the Scientology guards there's
Frank Paulo there's a bunch of them all
right Daniel says it's like a TV show
and we're all characters exactly it's
exactly what it's like and evidently
you'd have a new one now alright captain
Hanson tell us about captain Hanson
captain Hanson is like really handsome
his face is squashed though like when I
put his picture in Photoshop and double
it it's incredibly perfect but in real
life is his face is kind of like if you
took a hamburger and sat on it but it's
still working these children of the
Church of Scientology's few remaining
members that they're good-looking the
pressure on the parents to give them up
his intense and he's now a security
guard he's on the bike sometimes over a
big blue with some other guards like
Otto Huber and Roy but I saw him at the
Hollywood Information Center on
Hollywood Boulevard not far from the
Chinese Theatre and Harlan high and he's
so good-looking they it's like the
Scientologists have this magical future
Realtors or pharmaceutical
representatives of America core like
that region where you get these gorgeous
children you kill your ugly babies like
the Mormons do I mean is that also in
that different
yeah or they might be making them maybe
they're cyborgs yeah and then there's
then there's another one that you
thought was met he's always gripping on
a guy named angel and he just posted a
new video where he's on great and angels
there and said and next to Angel is a
swear to god this kind looks like a
human weasel I've never seen a man that
skinny who was that AGP oh was that the
guy who was like he was grey and
grizzled and he was like had a push
broom thing now you're standing next to
Angel he was blocking ingress there's a
guy standing next next to Angel in that
Scientology door I think he was either
related to Angel or maybe just another
Scientology kid but this is the
skinniest looking guy I've ever seen he
look like a human weasel i'ma show
pictures of him on the show I don't know
what he was sitting there looking at you
like you were from another clan I assume
this is another co-worker that has been
like a malnourished not use prob about
18 19 standing next to Angel he look
like a human weasel never seen buddy
stand that way it was an ode oh no what
no no you know that's common enough that
I might have missed it because I was
like distracted by Scientologists saying
we are going to arrest you at the time
were with it now you did show oh no no
no it has a new style he shaved his
beard I think kidding actually it
started looking but I'd like to still
can't stand on it as a bomb you know
anyone who anyone who gets me arrested
for four days on false charges like I'm
sorry you're ugly to rest of my life and
then it also does like Frank Paolo made
a surprise in money your videos yes I
have a lot of that material but I just
haven't had time to edit it because like
you know I have like my other jobs and
stuff like that I do but I want to get
donations higher I could spend more time
on it but until then you know it's going
to take a long time with this backlog of
national Fingal protesting so much stuff
but I got lots of frog from a yeast er
and we have I put up a little clip of it
where one of the times hall just shoves
me around and Frank and I get into a row
about it because like I was arrested for
just spanking a scientologist ass yes I
remember that
and was 2015 day one I had no camera you
can only see it in the Scientologists
own security videos they entered his
evidence against me
imagine what the DA's are saying their
board lives in this crazy crap comes
along like oh let's give it to the gay
judge and on that note we need to take a
break so we will be back with the angry
gay Pope in just a few minutes watch out
there's a new terror taking over
kitchens around the world thrills chills
mad cooking skills it cooks a weekly
podcast coming with recipes tips food
fines seasonal specials and guests
galore hosted by horror author amber
Fallon hey that's me a foodie with over
20 years experience cooking baking and
generally making a nuisance of herself
you watched Food Network you've read
cookbooks but nothing can prepare you
for it cooks coming to a device near you
some culture courses in clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount
subculture corsets calm or visit their
store in Jacksonville Florida just off
i-95 ladies and gentlemen Rogers
Entertainment Network presents oh boy
the mentor he's the greatest manager of
all time
mando Guerrero fortune aim of becoming
superstar good good good Ramon with
million in chocolate domain I'm not
gonna keep summers never Chuck how to
write a book maybe you do other edge the
Garson torkelson parents we know
marvelously on frontage Entertainment
Network
[Music]
[Music]
you
kgp I have another question can you
explain to me this video Santa ho me
what are they doing with Santa homie
there's a video I put up made a copy of
because I never wanted to go away of
this um black Scientologists who is at
the opening of Inglewood ideal were
accused of one of their black resented
tubes
he thinks he's want to be some rapper so
maybe he has money and they're sucking
it out of them I assume but he's like
this no-talent guy who of course has
come to Hollywood and they've they've
opened their doors for him and he's like
he took his eared
and he made it into two gangly little
like brave or whatever like and it looks
like there's like slobber or calm
dripping offers everything in this
Clearwater Christmas palace because what
better winter wonderland is there the
Florida soon to be under water from
steam and global warming and he sings
this song called Santa homie which I am
so naive I thought he wrote himself but
apparently it is another of the coming
so it has a cut from a ripoff of another
song pretty bad pretty bad sure when
Warner Music executives went to go after
with rights ago all churches I told it
would never mind look what about it well
yeah that's probably what is it isn't um
like Santa baby
Oh Santa homie that's the whole thing I
thought probably yet he's like mr. yo-yo
gangster in this white winter wonderland
for a space alien cold it's just
terribly maybe only in America real okay
okay here's another story a GP tell the
audience about the story of the the the
gate storming Scientologists yet so yeah
I wasn't planning on shooting a video
but I was going somewhere and I guess I
had my camera on and I came back from it
on the subway I was downtown and came
back on the subway at the Hollywood in
Ohio I come out and there's this
starving Scientology kid skinny and tall
like the kind you said saw before
obviously uh malnourished which is what
they do because if you if you don't get
enough sleep and go get enough protein
your brain doesn't wrap properly the
downside is you become really stupid you
have to be told eight times what to do
so like I've watched Scientologists were
angry talked to me
like Ava Paquette one of their lawyers
she like talked to me like I was a
idiotic [ __ ] you're like you know like
an attention span a four-second because
I'm about to pass out yes like you work
for free and you haven't had enough to
eat but you're still going and no you're
an idiotic [ __ ] I can't get you to do
anything problem so like he's really
skinny and I saw him there and like I
turn on the camera so basically my thing
is a well I don't under cover you'll see
that the screen switches to four by
three it's not widescreen its likes
black bars on both sides that can mean
that I am undercover and they don't know
that there's this like camera hanging
around my neck
recording low resolution video and nice
stereo sound of everything they say so I
walk up to them like I'm c-3po but
actually I'm this bug-eyed little r2d2
with this eyeball watching them right
around coming out on my belly button
everything I do involves distracting
them so they don't look at that while I
manipulate the camera like tilting it up
or down or whatever oppressing taking
pictures and he just completely fell for
it and this guy was giving out brochures
even though he was clearly being
punished and wearing all black and
looked horrible images he's probably
sent out there maybe to make amends or
to maybe instead of being on the gulag
for a little while you could be a body
router which is one of the lowest jobs
in Scientology so you have to be really
low to be excited to be handing
brochures out and stuff brochures which
lets people throw on the ground within
50 feet if they take the mill I made
sure to get him in trouble and point out
to him that I'm a major protester a
suppressive person and SP and that at
100 said you shouldn't be talking to
them and like you're doing it so great
leader has all these rules for what you
should do and I know what they are and
he wasn't doing them because all but I
like you what I like to do is I take
these little glimmers of humanity and
creativity or protest and spunk that
they may exhibit and just crush them
let's talk about this talk about
Scientology the more on camera that I
identify myself as the enemy and they
engage with me as a human being
they're like worse it is for them later
so it really crashed and last bit of
time a person I know
a GP let me ask you a question if a
Scientologist has sex with somebody are
they having sex just with that person or
with a whole bunch of other people also
what could what they believe any type of
realities can you can you explain this
well first of all with Scientologists
and sex I mean when you're a public
Scientologist who just goes into Church
or whatever and comes back they want to
hear everything about you you and Haley
a boob job where you slept it what they
want to know everything your sex life
your sex peccadilloes so that they can
blackmail you and so that they can
connect with other Scientologists you're
sleeping with and know everything that
goes on about everyone at their most
personal level then second level of sex
is in the C organization which is their
priesthood you can't have sex with
someone who's outside the Sea Org and if
you do and find out that people have
done that just to get kicked out because
I wanted out one guy went to a strip
club in his Sea Org uniform dressed like
a sailor and told them all about it
loudly - look you could get kicked out
ironically that's the easy way if the
hard way is I would like to leave and
then they tear you apart for six months
and you don't leave anyway
so that so sex embassy org is very
limited and you're not allowed to
masturbate and you're not allowed to
date people outside the Sea Org but you
never have time to meet anyone of the
opposite sex in the Sea Org anyway so
like it's a massively sexually repressed
shame on you for masturbating people
sleeping around behind the scenes and
breaking the law constantly because the
law is so stupid and phony so that's
another level of sex in Scientology and
then the final level is we get down into
the level of dynamics of best ones and
twos sex and Scientology is like each
person is not a person it's a ever
reincarnating phaeton so you are all the
people you were in the past and might
even be in the future so like they tell
everyone that everyone was basically
Luke Skywalker a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away because it could be
in another galaxy and the galaxies are
huge number of people you more things
you could be on different planets as
your Phaeton spins around why wouldn't
you die I believe that you your state in
orbits Phoenix a couple times I'm not I
told Ron Hubbard the creator had the
rules for everything but I'm not here to
bad-mouth everyone Hubbard but because
of that stipulation that everybody is a
reincarnating being each
kara nation is like a little unit in a
centipede so when you have sex with that
person you're theoretically having sex
with all the people that they were in
the past which is like more legs on a
centipede
so we aren't just one human being we are
like a centipede and you're only
experiencing one little segment of the
centipede with its two little legs and
you know you put all together and
there's like whatever like dirty you're
sorry so you're not just having sex it's
not just sex it's more than that it's
sex with a centipede yeah I think I saw
that movie I don't want to see that
movie again one thing I've noticed I've
noticed Scientologists even like
ex-scientologists they believe in what
they call the town scale even if they
don't realize they do I guess if they if
you become a Scientologist early on it's
hard to get this thinking out of their
head yeah that one of the benefits of
Scientology is that plans to be
scientific which means dividing things
of the scales and groups and
individually understandable concepts
instead of bags and was like oh you know
what does that mean so the town scale is
their way of relating to people kind of
like some people use horoscopes and
instead of being a Gemini or a Leo or
whatever you're you're up and down on
this thermometer that gets better the
higher you're going worse the lower you
go and so on one point one on the tone
scale is a homosexual
which means I'm really scummy and each
one has a position like one there's like
a position of danger and you know like
72 is a position of hooray I mean their
conditions and like when when you see
Scientologists protest and they go over
the other Scientologists legal because
what we're doing today you're going to a
lower condition yeah your your length
rank on the tone scale and they all have
one is going to go down and you'll be
treated like a certain way like if
you're in a condition of treason like
you are like probably locked in a
medical waste incinerator for five
months at a time while they drug your
food until you want to start Rochelle
someone like me who is an outsider who's
one point one on the tone scale is like
considered a homosexual just as degraded
being a DB it's horrible and someone
like Tom Cruise he's clearly gay and I'm
not going to get into that today with
him and left
the same prostitutes his people have
slept with but I slept with him for
[ __ ] free yeah it's weird because uh
let's assume Tom Cruise is a homosexual
he's 1.1 on the tone scale so he should
be horrible but because he's rich and
famous
he's a wonderful Scientologist and we're
going to clear you of that we're going
to get you above you higher on the tone
scale and so maybe he overcompensates
with his raw Rob Scientology in a
condition of having this boy does he
have it so many places anyway but he's
selling off now but using a condition of
having this not 1.17 tone scale is a
theoretical thing that they tell the
people but in reality they don't pay
attention to is do that and you're rich
especially famous like oh you're really
hot on the tone scale okay yeah because
I've actually like picked up from you
just the things that you said that there
are certain you're not ex-scientologists
they don't really approve the protests
that you do against Scientology and I
really think that's because they
actually see things in terms of the tone
scale a normal person sees what you do
and just laugh at it and enjoy after a
while I think they internalize it yeah
plenty of non Scientologists find me
offensive so I'm not sure you I'm going
to you know but I I kind of it's a shock
value thing but I know which I am NOT
what you're saying
internal izing it because they I point
out their own guilt and their own flaws
and then they like put up a blinder like
no he's just a jerk you know well that's
like don't that's like watching The
Exorcist and saying there's too much
vomit in that movie ok you know that
like the demon is in the house and like
I don't vomit they'd be lucky if they
when I see some of these people I care
them apart
the people who are watching at home that
criticized me who are exes you know are
maybe possibly internalizing it but
that's just too bad because the people
that are on the street in Hollywood
doing bad things even that skinny kid is
handing out brochures for a personality
test designed to hurt people so that
they will like crawl to Scientology
begging for help so so like you better
believe the demons in the house and
there's going to be plenty of vomit in
this video
you'll be lucky if it's pea soup because
usually it's just going to be vodka and
orange
I think a lot of it has to do not only
with just like this I intelligent own
scale but I think it has to do with
generational differences too because you
notice that you know Gen X and younger
they understand the concept of trolling
yeah older generations and especially
Scientology because it's based on 1950s
versions of morality they don't
understand that trolling is an effective
tool yeah they don't get it yeah they
don't seem to it's like oh that's
immoral
doesn't matter if it's for a good I mean
and one thing I noticed because like I
lived in Clearwater for awhile and I
worked for a company that was full of
them that was owned by Scientologists
and a bunch of people and they really
don't have much of a sense of humor know
about anything no sense of humor no
concept of how useful trolling an enemy
is like they didn't like if I said like
real passive aggressive like [ __ ] a
[ __ ] to them it's like say they didn't
have they just like what blackface they
don't get it they either take it
literally or don't react kind of a thing
yeah those people you saw with the note
and that workplace and you've seen
Scientology closer than I have believe
it or not because of your position those
people that have no sense of humor they
have no sense of irony they can't put
things in quotes you know what I mean
they don't understand polling that's one
side of it but the flip side of it is
OSA those are the Sheep the Wolves of
Scientology oh so they really understand
trolling no yet you just watched those
incredibly childish ape videos they make
I mean they are the kings of trolling
and they would hire people or take over
anonymous websites like why we protest
Neda just infiltrate and troll and take
over and like one sleazy P I would have
10 sock puppet names and all log on at
once to badmouth me and they would all
agree that I stink as if it mattered
though they do like I see them of the
some of the websites that they've made
like against people that spoke out
against them and stuff like that if
they're really lame I thought they were
lame they're not not effective nobody
buys into that nobody cares and I would
say especially nowadays like the stuff
that they're like oh we have all this
dirt on you it's like nobody gives a
[ __ ] about that mouth nobody cares
19:55 right now being interested the
true care of Tom Cruise or John Travolta
was gay I mean is like [ __ ]
Carrie Fisher said before she died like
charger both they're all talking about
you you know we're talking about you
just like get over it but they can but
like you see just like I said that the
security was on us the minute we walked
into the idea organ Inglewood because
nobody goes in there it's like would you
have seen that video of the hate things
that you weren't interested in it to
begin with no course not the only the
only audience that hate video is made
for is the great leader David Miscavige
and that's why it's so childish and
stupid and living in a bubble world kind
of a view and you thought it was
incredibly unhip and tacky I'm sure is
only made for him and if you watch the
videos that Saddam Hussein made about
his enemies or what North Korea makes
about people they have the same
incompetent bullshitter II to them
except that Scientologists have better
production values than Saddam did you
know worried not going to worry about
Lia remedies drones flying over his
house
Leah Remini doesn't have drones her show
just takes a vantage of the free drone
footage I gave them that a we got to put
some of that if you go o up in some of
my Twin Peaks buck stuff we can talk
about in a minute but no it's not drones
from Leah Remini has to worry about
first of all I heard a couple days ago
before it broke on Tony arte his blog
Tony Ortega dot-org that a and he is
going to earn out a lifetime is going to
do a cheapy Lifetime movie of her book
Lea remedies book I can't remember the
name of it but anyway troublemaker don't
worry about it Leah Remini book we know
and so she's got a second season of her
work that my stuff is going to be on
again and they're doing particular they
they particularly like the Twin Peaks
stuff and things involving
Scientologists various legal people I've
lots of footage of that over the years
so you can expect to see some of that
and the nice thing about the Twin Peaks
thing is like as that the production
person told me they're oh good good I'm
not sure well we'll use this but it
really lets us use some new
concentration camp images because like
the ones we were using with your ultra
barrier whole
her leg like we've overused those now
we've got new black ones covered with
spider webs and forest filth she things
like that but that's what she'd made
[Music]
okay
ok AGP what do you want to talk about
they wanted nothing honest so nasty
Nathaniel and if you go to youtube and
search for nastier families you can see
it's anti-cop videos and a lesbian
protester named GI Johnny who's an
ex-marine we all drove out to Twin Peaks
secret base where church leaders out
Kelly Sian shelling this cabbage is
allegedly stored and it's the secret
base where they built a vault into the
ground of where L 100 words are stored
on metal plates in inner gas in a sort
of extraterrestrial Tupperware there's a
separate in a dented they cannot rust
they will not be exposed to the outside
world they do not know who was it it is
[Music]
they are there forever and we went up
there to see the one part of it we
hadn't seen before
so the police ended up coming after us
because they charged the design colleges
are called in charges with trespassing
and like the police came and they spend
like half an hour with us so it's like
bog police cars and four police cars
five cops and like you could have found
Shelly Miscavige by this time if you
would like invested this much effort
into that instead of seeing whether
we're trespassing or not so they said
that we might be trespassing it's just
ridiculous so I mean we did was first we
went to a nearby Christian compound and
trespass there and then we parked our
car there without their permission
because GI Jenny had discovered that if
we park there we can sneak through the
woods and see the one part I haven't
recorded yet by trespassing
they own this Big Woods but there was no
strap there were no no trespassing signs
I saw one sign that was really faded
that I think said don't big here because
there's an underground gas line but
there were no no trespassing signs even
though I knew the property was
Scientology they don't say so so it's
not trespassing is
so we get to the bottom and then there's
a no trespassing sign right on this big
scary fence full of spikes an ultra
barrier which is three inch long
aluminum porcupine quill things
unfortunately that no trespassing sign
was not large enough I did not cite the
proper California code therefore it's an
illegal bit trespassing front if they
had put up a legal no trespassing sign
teenagers would be there all the time
bothering them because it draws
attention to it and like eventually
people teenagers in boring town figure
out what's fun to do in their
neighborhood because I've nothing else
around and we looked and this was
through the woods the back of their
compound which is known for being a
security fence and there was this long
suspension bridge that was beautiful
that was built about a hundred years ago
when this was a rich compound for the
ultra-wealthy of Los Angeles who who was
a big enough City now that they wanted
some place to go there was out of the
way it was not the quote big city and
you're up thousands of feet in the air
and you could like see beyond the desert
pass Palm Springs to the ocean on a
really sunny day you could see a little
bit of Pacific Ocean on the horizon it's
so high up it's called rim of the world
rating the world no no I'm trying to
talk about religious matters the next
thing you know we're going to talk about
amoebic dysentery and other diseases you
can get from that
so it's a beautiful place and the
buildings are gorgeous and they're over
100 years old and here was this
beautiful suspension bridge that ended
in this ultra barrier zoo fencing inside
other fencing so there's a there's like
a suspension bridge and at the end of it
just like in a video game is a fenced-in
area and you can't get out of it and it
makes me wonder if there were that might
be a place they stored Shelley at
certain times over the decade or so
she's been there and along the fence
stuck on the ultra barrier where these
pink ribbons and it was very sad like
who keeps putting these pink ribbons up
it's like is it a tribute to someone I
assume a woman if it's a children to a
woman is it Shelley I don't know
but we found pink ribbon so I'm not
saying why they're there we didn't put
them there and that's obvious from the
photographs because they are like
sunburned and covered with dust and
obviously look like they've been there
for some time so you're telling us you
think you know where their key is
keeping um David Miscavige's wife well I
don't think that but other
Scientologists who have left say that
her mail was forwarded to that location
for years okay look like that she's
there and I would if I was going to
store her I would always stole her in
the middle and I would never let her go
out but we met a woman there who was on
Tony Ortegas blog and has talked to me I
will talk much more about her because
she wants to be anonymous but she she's
pretty sure she saw selling Miscavige
over the past year or so in the local
stores looking emaciated and with two
young twenty 30-something handlers who
were very close on her this woman's a
reputable source that has worked in the
criminal justice system and
unfortunately because there's so many
meth addicts there she has a big
security thing around her house with
dogs because there's so many meth
addicts you have to have that in the
country otherwise it's to wallace in san
bernardino can you believe it
so she can't be fair gained so they
could they can't go through her garbage
but she's been followed and she showed
up and she gave us a little sign to put
on there and we let that sign there and
as we were walking along taking all
these incriminating photos we just saw
some lady inside with it was like she's
wearing an outfit looked like what they
used to wear now with the little gray
pinstripes but she was really fat so it
was like fat outfits cannot leave this
place but it's a rich place and we're
for money and so like you're gonna get
fat here because you can't walk long
enough in one direction to lose weight
and the police came well first we
trespassed on to some of their area and
took pictures that were very
incriminating and then the police came
and they said boot these are the Georgia
with trespassing and we trismus and I
said no we true and like the good news
is well the bad news is technically we
were trespassing it as I knew what I was
doing all along but the good news is
that didn't do any damage
we're just taking pictures and they
didn't properly document where you're
nuts what's trespass
and no police report was filed despite
the fact that there were five cop cars
there so like I could say this you know
that their legal department is now
writing all this down I trust you
because a man talked about this film how
I
I haven't even run it past my lawyer but
well the point is they can't do anything
because the main nastiness of
trespassing is like they told us to
leave in that area we left but we didn't
break anything touched any things - only
thing we went through there for us but
we did not take any would that's a big
deal in California like if I would take
a piece of wood out of air that would
have been more serious if I had taken
one of their oysters that would be very
serious because there's these big
trespassing laws in California but you
can't take oysters and I'm like well
like 50 miles from the coast and up well
here so I know Easter's yeah we broke
them oh yeah we trespass that what are
you going to do about it what are you
gonna do about it okay jeez no tonight
they will change the signs they'd
probably taken those little pink ribbons
down they're going to put up much more
fencing and when I was there in 2010
they afterwords planted so much fencing
they have double gates now there was
used to be when I worked there walked up
there the first time they had a Gabe you
could just walk up to this big glass
window that was you know bullet
resistant and talked to whoever's inside
through a microphone now they have a
second gate so you have to like go
through the first gate and there's all
these plantings that are guess what
thorny and painful and large there have
been growing for seven years I the angry
gay Pope make an appearance and they
make their holy amends by planting
plants in honor of Earth Day and stuff I
walked along the fence and there was a
place where the bushes had died off and
they needed to put more in and I saw all
these white polyvinyl chloride PVC pipe
sticking out that where theyíre gate it
so I can sit here happy and smiling
knowing that they are wasting water and
all this money and landscaping expenses
and stuff on me just because I showed up
in 2010 and now I've shown up again
they're gonna have to write some more
chairs I guess so what you got what you
got planned AGP I think I'm coming up
why probably top secret huh well this
weekend there's going to be a diversity
march in West Hollywood so I'm going to
be covering that and talking to some of
the sheriff's deputies here because the
sheriff's and West Hollywood are really
funny it's really funny that kind of
stuff and they'll be that'd be a more
festive video but so I've got nastiness
annual at gold base where a police
officer supports Scientology and it's
that's going to be a big show that is
nobody's protested at their home world
which is gold based in Riverside
California where they have a big movie
studio in a long time so I'm using that
as an excuse is a wonderful clip show
it's going to be all about that place
using nasty Nathaniel and his friend in
it as the police stumble around with
what they do is they just call the
police willy-nilly and throw mud at the
wall and they said someone's fighting in
the street and the chips officer arrives
and like there's just two guys there
meanwhile nasty Nathaniel is dressed
like a terrorist which did not help okay
you do not dress like a terrorist mode
or things I'll do this a reason why I
wear rainbow shirt fuzzy blue pants a
pro pad in a spooky mask I mean like do
not look conventional or a terrorist
okay you watch you go ahead watch you go
ahead and plug okay angry gay poke calm
is my website and you can find links
there too if you want to become a patron
or donate to help me fight Scientology
it's a patreon PAP REO and calm slash
anger gay Pope if you go to YouTube just
search for angry gay Pope or Google
angry gay Pope also on Facebook and
Twitter but the main deal is angry gay
Pope comma go see the history of
everything in the detail all it pictures
and video links to YouTube which is my
also other really big thing I have over
400 videos on YouTube going through the
years you can you can see Scientologist
aging before your eyes well true I'm a
medically useful by remaining off camera
that's the secret right there you got to
do well thanks so much for having me on
guys it's always fun to catch up with
you to a you to Florida hipsters yeah
it's good to have you back with then
nine months since you've been on it we
got to have you back on before the end
of the year - yeah let's see uh you know
July is a big protest month that they
have a lot of things that nasty thing
wants to go to and then and then in
November you've got that the Christmas
parade in the opening of hopefully
they'll have l ron Hubbard's winter
wonderland again and that's always a
cornucopia of interaction possibilities
so by the time by the time we get to
December it'd be perfect why don't we
say in December so that's about six
months from yeah yeah that's that sounds
good you know how to contact us and when
it goes down just drop us a line we'll
have you back on because I know the
audience loves you they're gonna want to
catch up with you so much end of called
line and end of table okay and that was
the second interview that we did with
the angered a Pope yeah we'll have him
back again
and we'll definitely have him back out
we were talking about having back in
December which i think is yeah he's a
funny Gastner bit seems to like him yeah
he is very funny guy and like I said
check out his website anchor Dave Pope
calm and check out his youtube channel
he has hundreds and hundreds of very
entertaining videos that there of him
trolling various Scientologists and
going to their secret bases and taking
pictures of all the weird security
measures they've taken and yeah you just
sit there and binge watch for hours he's
good at a technology or unbelievable and
like all the weird like security you
think it was Fort Knox of the other
marketplaces where they're crazy for
real and like I said I think I mentioned
it on the first year but I used to work
at a company I used to live in
Clearwater which is like their their big
like hub and I used to work at a company
it wasn't like a Scientology Church or
anything but it was a company that was
owned by Scientologists and a bunch of
people that worked there were signs
ologist so that's what we were talking
about in the interview that I had worked
there with them and I only worked there
eight months and then I kind of ran away
screaming because they were so nuts and
I couldn't take it anymore yeah you talk
about down the first yeah so I think I
mentioned that before but you know in
case you're too lazy to go back and yeah
it was oh okay I want anything else
books yeah buy my book yeah review my
book and if you want a free copy of one
of the audiobooks
dicin we can get you something yeah I go
to our Facebook page 13 o'clock podcast
go to our Twitter page which is also
which is also 13 o'clock podcast like
follow blah blah
you guys know oh and go to zazzle.com /
13 o'clock podcast for the shirts wash
no no no shirt t-shirt I just said that
by hand
follow I have the code the code do that
II the key to the secret the secret a
space its neuro tality religion and
science intertwine them inside of our
minds billion your contract we have
thank you don't make sense to me
[Music]
[Music]